[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american crime comedy film
called little man
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
calvin sims is a convicted jewelry thief
serving prison time in chicago in the
opening scene he orders a fellow inmate
to count the number of pull-ups for him
by the looks of it calvin is a tough guy
respected by all the inmates on the day
calvin is let free he walks out of the
prison and reveals that he suffers from
dwarfism and is barely three feet tall
his friend and fellow thief percy picks
him up accidentally hitting him with the
car door while he is at it percy doesn't
waste time before informing calvin of
their next heist a dangerous gang leader
walken has appointed percy to steal a
diamond from a jewelry shop for a
hundred thousand dollars calvin who
thoroughly enjoyed his time in prison
doesn't care about being convicted again
hence he accepts the deal following that
we are introduced to the edward couple
the husband daryl is a family man who
wants to have a child as soon as
possible his wife vanessa is also keen
on starting a family but wants to
prioritize work for the next few years
the couple is at a restaurant where
vanessa says she has good news to share
with daryl not giving her a chance to
disclose what exactly the news is daryl
announces that she is pregnant to the
rest of the restaurant everyone claps
and cheers for the couple while vanessa
embarrassingly claims that it is not the
case the good news is that she got
promoted at work a disheartened daryl
congratulates her which doesn't go
unnoticed by vanessa recently there has
been a rift in the couple's relationship
because of their different desires
somewhere else calvin and percy go to a
jewelry shop to steal the diamond percy
puts calvin in a bag and takes him
inside while he distracts the store
manager calvin swiftly goes under the
display and steals the diamond
everything goes according to plan until
a chihuahua chases after calvin and gets
inside the bag with him the dog's owner
freaks out after hearing it bark from
inside percy's bag as the burglars run
away the store manager notices the
missing diamond and calls the police
suddenly percy comes to a halt because
he feels a sharp pain in his leg calvin
thinks he was shot but it turns out that
he just pulled a muscle the duo runs
into a convenience store to hide while
still being followed by the police
coincidentally the edward couple is also
at the store arguing as usual in a
moment of panic calvin puts the diamond
in vanessa's bag in order to not be
caught with it himself a while later the
policemen go away thinking that they
lost the thieves after that calvin and
percy follow the couple to their home in
the next scene we are introduced to
vanessa's father pops he is living with
the couple because of his old age daryl
and pop hardly ever get along because
pop thinks daryl's unworthy of his
daughter even now he comments how daryl
cannot get his daughter pregnant because
he has no bullets in his chamber
shooting blanks as it were vanessa
settles the argument and stands firm
that she will only have a baby when she
is ready outside percy gets ready with a
gun to get the diamond back but calvin
insists they need to think of a better
plan a lady pushing a stroller gives
percy a genius idea the next day calvin
shaves his beard and gets inside a
basket to pose as a baby percy puts him
outside the couple's door and runs away
hoping that they will take calvin in
when daryl comes outside calvin imitates
baby noises
[Music]
[Applause]
and the man buys into the obviously
staged act they bring the baby inside
and try to change his diapers although
what's under his diapers surprises the
family they dismiss it initially the
family calls child services but is
informed that the offices won't open
until after the weekend their second
option is to take the baby to a doctor
to check if he's doing all right the
doctor finds sketchy things like a
tattoo on the baby's arm and a surgery
scar however he thinks the child is
overall normal and lets the couple take
him home when daryl and vanessa are busy
discussing what they should do next
calvin bolts outside with vanessa's
purse but a policeman catches him on the
way and hands him back to vanessa the
baby calls her mama mama
which melts her heart so she decides to
keep him until they find his parents
somewhere else percy meets the gangster
walking who suspects they have fled with
his diamond he threatens percy to get it
back in 24 hours or else both he and
calvin will be dead by the 25th hour
back at home little calvin startles pops
who mistakes him for chucky pops clearly
doesn't like him and his presence in the
house but he is ready to compromise for
his daughter that evening vanessa and
daryl hold a party to officially welcome
calvin to the family a couple of their
friends come over who at first think
calvin is an ugly child one friend tries
to be nice and calls him adorable in a
national geographic kind of way although
calvin is acting like a baby he cannot
suppress his manly urges he holds on to
one of vanessa's friends and tries
grabbing her when she leans down to give
him a goodbye kiss he even forcefully
makes out with her the couple thinks
it's weird but chooses to ignore it
later at night calvin tries getting
close to vanessa on several occasions
first he cutely invites her to bathe
with him then he pushes her head when
she tries to tickle him before going to
bed the couple puts him inside his crib
and makes him fall asleep calvin wakes
up in the middle of the night and
finally decides to do the work that he's
there for he jumps out of the crib and
goes downstairs to call percy while he's
at it pops finds him talking like an
adult and is happy that he was right
about the big baby right then daryl also
wakes up but he doesn't believe pops's
claims about the kid daryl thinks calvin
is hungry and makes him a bottle he also
sympathizes with the kid and his
presumably bad childhood calvin who has
never had a father figure talk to him
like that is actually touched by daryl's
words a while later vanessa and daryl
get steamy in bed they feel slightly
uncomfortable because calvin cannot stop
staring at them still daryl claims that
the kid doesn't know what's going on and
gets under the blankets the next morning
vanessa wakes up with a magical glow and
compliments daryl and his newfound
skills in bed daryl is confused because
he didn't do anything new just then
calvin is revealed to have climbed into
the bed sometime at night comedy in the
early 2000s was disturbing the couple
doesn't think much of it and ends the
conversation the following day vanessa
goes to work leaving daryl responsible
to take care of the child while he is
busy calvin manages to get hold of the
diamond from vanessa's purse now he only
has to think of a way to escape the
household without making a big fuss
later daryl brings calvin to a park for
a father-son quality time however the
quality time is not fun for daryl
because the kid hits him in the crotch
several times when no one is looking
percy arrives at the park and asks
calvin for the diamond but the parents
notice him and chase him away before he
can get it the diamond is in the diaper
bag that daryl puts in the car's trunk
calvin takes the opportunity to run away
with the entire car a naive daryl still
thinks that someone stole his car and
his child he hitchhikes in a ladies
vehicle who drives like there is no
tomorrow by the end of the chase daryl
is sobbing saying that the baby is not
worth the risk of driving with her a
police car stops calvin at last but
believes that the suspect ran away
without the baby somewhere else percy
goes to the gangster with a random
diaper bag he picked up from the park
earlier walken digs into the bag but
finds dirty diapers instead of the
diamond still the gangster gives percy
some more time to get the real diamond
he then secretly asks his henchmen to
follow him and kill both percy and his
partner if they aren't able to retrieve
the rock the next day daryl and his
friends take calvin to an ice hockey
game when no one is looking calvin grabs
the diamond from the diaper bag as daryl
turns to him he quickly puts the rock in
his mouth and swallows it to not get
caught the game goes well until calvin
kat calls a server and gets daryl in
trouble upon returning home the couple
puts calvin to sleep and decides to
throw him a birthday party the following
day at the party calvin is bored out of
his mind however when it's time to cut
the cake he gets emotional because no
one has ever shown him this much love he
is genuinely thankful that he got
parents who take such great care of him
at the same time pops is at a diner when
he sees calvin's face in the news he
finds out the kid is actually a dwarf
criminal and is ready to expose him he
runs to the party and gives him a teddy
bear as a present what calvin doesn't
know is that the teddy bear has a hidden
camera inside after the birthday party
calvin drinks a bottle of laxatives to
help him get the diamond out the plan
works but vanessa finds the diamond
while changing his diaper she believes
that it is a surprise gift from her
husband and jumps up on top of him in
excitement daryl tries to explain that
the diamond isn't from him but she
doesn't give him a chance to talk they
go to dinner that night leaving pops to
babysit calvin after the couple leaves
he pretends to play with calvin and
throws him to the ground eventually
calvin has to come clean to him but he
threatens pops and tells him not to tell
anyone meanwhile in the restaurant
vanessa tells daryl that she is ready to
adopt calvin and make him their own they
excitedly return home only to find pops
strangling calvin horrified by the
action they kick him out of the house
and take calvin to his room before being
pulled away pops tells his daughter to
look at the teddy because he knows
everything daryl checks the stuffed toy
and finds out it's actually a camera he
connects it to the tv and discovers a
recording of calvin admitting the truth
he immediately heads to the bedroom only
to find that calvin has already run away
in the following scene calvin and percy
are back together celebrating that they
finally got the diamond percy reveals
that the gangsters are after daryl and
his family because they think the couple
stole the stone realizing that the
family's in danger calvin returns to
help them meanwhile vanessa leaves to
look for her father when daryl is alone
walken and two of his henchmen come to
the house and hold him hostage just then
calvin arrives and pretends to be a
child because the henchmen underestimate
him he manages to beat them up at the
same time daryl fights walken the fight
goes on for quite a while before the
police arrive at the scene they arrest
the criminals and ask daryl about the
kid daryl feels indebted to calvin for
coming to help him so he saves him from
the police they're also informed that
they will receive a hundred thousand
dollars for helping the police find the
diamond when the two are left alone in
the house calvin thanks daryl for
everything and wishes him farewell but
when he reaches outside he starts crying
at the thought that he'll never have a
family again daryl feels bad and is
genuinely sad that calvin has to go at
last just like ash with pikachu he makes
the decision to keep calvin as a family
member in the final scene calvin and
pops are playing with vanessa's newborn
kid to everyone's surprise the kid looks
exactly like calvin
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching